>> WELCOME BACK TO "BEHIND THE
SLIME," A LOOK BACK AT THE
HISTORY OF NICKELODEON'S ICONIC
GREEN GOO.
I'M NICK CANNON, FORMER STAR OF
"ALL THAT."
>> AND I'M MARK SUMMERS, FORMER
HOST OF "DOUBLE DARE," "SUPER
SLOPPY DOUBLE DARE," AND THE
ILL-FATED "DIRTY NASTY HARDCORE
DOUBLE DARE."
>> AMERICA WAS INTRODUCED TO
NICKELODEON'S ON THE CANADIAN
KIDS' COMEDY SHOW "YOU CAN'T DO
THAT ON TELEVISION."
>> GREEN SLIME WOULD RAIN DOWN
ON ANYBODY WHO SAYS THE PHRASE,
"I DON'T KNOW."
BUT AS YOU'LL SEE IN THIS
FOOTAGE FROM AN EARLY EPISODE,
THE SLIME DIDN'T START OUT WITH
ITS NOW ICONIC LOOK.
>> HEAD'S UP.
THIS SHOW WAS MADE IN CANADA, SO
THOSE KIDS ARE WHITE AS HELL.
>> OKAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HEY, TRACY.
>> HEY, CHRISTINA.
>> YOU GOT A RUBIX CUBE?
>> NOT REALLY.
I'M COLOR BLIND.
>> WAIT.
YOU'RE COLOR BLIND AND YOUR
PARENTS ARE DIVORCED?
NO WONDER YOU DON'T HAVE A
BOYFRIEND.
>> AGAIN, THIS IS FROM 1980 WHEN
TV WAS CRAZY.
>> YOU KNOW, I HAVE ALWAYS
WONDERED, WHO EXACTLY IS THIS
RUBIK GUY.
>> HUH.
I DON'T KNOW.
OH, MY GOD!
THAT WAS LIKE CONCRETE.
>> I CAN'T BELIEVE YOU SAID, "I
DON'T KNOW."
OOPS.
>> OH, GEEZ.
WHAT WAS THAT?
>> SORRY!
LITTLE BASTARD SLIPPED OUT OF MY
HANDS.
YEAH.
SLIME IS TOO DAMN THICK.
>> FUN FACT.
THAT WOMAN WITH THE BUSTED ASS
HAIR CUT IS BECKY.
>> THE EARLY DAYS ALSO SAW
EXPERMITATION IN THE METHODS OF
SLIMING, AS SEEN IN THIS CLIP
FROM AN EARLY EPISODE.
>> YOU'RE SO FUNNY
SUZANNE SUMMERS.
>> IT'S MARK SUMMERS.
>> OKAY, MY BAD.
>> HEY, GREG.
>> HEY, MARCY.
THIS SPIDERMAN COMIC GOT ME
THINKING, YOU'D BE A GREAT
SUPERHERO.
STUFFED HER BRA WOMAN.
>> OH, WELL YOU CAN BE MY
SIDEKICK, THE INCREDIBLE HOMO.
>> 1980.
>> NO.
I PREFER SUPER CRAIG.
>> HUH.
AND WHAT'S SUPER CRAIG'S SUPER
POWER?
>> HA, I DON'T KNOW.
I GUESS -- JESUS CHRIST.
>> HA HA.
LOOKS LIKE SUPER CRAIG'S SUPER
POWER IS BEING SLIMED.
>> OKAY!
>> WHY DID THEY DO THAT TO ME?
>> I DON'T KNOW, BUT THEY JUST
KEEP COMING AT US.
OH.
DAMMIT, STOP, PLEASE.
THAT HURT.
I'M SERIOUS.
>> YOU KNOW, THE ISSUE IS FIXED,
AND IT WILL NOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> OKAY.
STOP.
WE'RE BEGGING YOU.
>> OKAY.
THE SECOND TO LAST EPISODE
SHOWED A GLIMMER OF THE SLIME WE
KNOW TODAY, BUT THERE WERE STILL
SOME ISSUES TO IRON OUT.
SLIME IS ONE STICKY BUSINESS.
>> HELL, YEAH.
JUST LIKE HAVING 18 KIDS WITH
20 DIFFERENT WOMEN.
I'M LOSING MY HAIR.
>> HEY.
>> GEE, WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU,
ABBIE?
ARE YOU ON YOUR PERIOD OR
SOMETHING?
>> NO.
SHE'S PROBABLY JUST UPSET
BECAUSE SHE'S ADOPTED.
>> I MEAN, DO I GOT TO SAY IT?
>> 1980.
>> THEY KNOW, MAN.
>> I HAVE A QUESTION.
ARE YOU DWEEBS EVER NOT
ANNOYING?
>> HUH.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> OH, MAN.
>> ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT.
I FEEL LIKE YOU CAN STOP SOON.
>> IT'S GETTING IN MY EYES RIGHT
NOW.
>> IS IT OKAY IF I GET IT IN MY
MOUTH?
I FEEL LIKE YOU GOT IT.
>> PLEASE STOP.
CAN YOU PLEASE?
>> AFTER THAT EPISODE OF SLIME
TIME WAS SHORTENED FROM SIX
MINUTES TO FIVE SECONDS.
>> STAY TUNED.
AFTER THE BREAK, WE'LL BE JOINED
BY ONE OF
THE PETES FROM "THE ADVENTURES
WITH PETE AND PETE."